So actually, I'm not white,
so calm yourself down.
The reason, the way that I came to this conclusion
was in researching my own culture and my own history
and my own privilege.
I realized what I did was wrong in going on a mission trip to Fiji
because I am Puerto Rican.
My mother and my father are both 100% from Puerto Rico,
the island. Their parents are both from Puerto Rico.
But I was very confused at why do I look so white?
Why do I look so American?
I've passed for white my entire life.
I get all kinds of white privilege,
and I get to kind of pop in and out of my white privilege
or my not white privilege.
And in growing up and learning
and evolving and deconstructing my faith,
I realized the reason I look the way I look is because of colonialism.
Because of white Europeans from Spain settling in Puerto Rico,
mating and having children with the Taino Indians that live there.
That's why I look the way I look.
I have the high cheekbones,
but I also have the really light skin.
But I have dark hair and dark eyes,
but olive tone,
not like pink undertones.
Like, I've always been very confused at why do I look the way I look.
I'm ostracized from my Latina,
you know, people,
but then the white people don't accept me either.
So
once I started to look into my own culture and Why I am the way I am,
I Learned. And now I gave an apology to Fiji,
and I actually did look up some of their culture.
It was one of the most meaningful trips to me I still have.
I still,
uh, I.
I didn't wanna mispronounce any of the words.
I realized they don't do a haka.
What they do. It's spelled C I B I.
I don't really know how to pronounce it.
I didn't wanna be further disrespectful,
so I didn't wanna act like I know anything.
All I wanted to do
and what I will continue to do
is apologize to the nation of Fiji
and anybody that I try to convert that.
You know what I mean?
That's not my fucking place.
Your spirituality,
your culture, your faith,
all that shit is very personal.
And it's not anybody's job to be
proselyphizing and trying to change people's mind.
Like, let them come to that decision on their own and. Yeah,
so chill the fuck out.
I'm not white.